You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from
W. N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab. The podcast at it is, it is almost new years. Actually,
we were recording this a few hours before New Year's Eve. Well, it's not a few.
I mean today's Monday, tomorrow night, so 20 hours. We have 50 hours left. No,
any less than that 20 well, whatever. I just, because it's that time of year,
I want to tell you a story about a discovery I made it or not me.
I just learned about it from other people,
but it has made me completely reconsider what a year means and specifically how
big a year really is.
How big a year it, what, how big a year really is.
I don't know what, how, how is a year?
How long have you or confused now I think I can confuse you even more.
I'm going to begin this investigation by introducing new two little creature in
the sea called a coral
corals. Is Shelly animal a little creature? It's a, there's Antiel Schupan.
I'm a paleontologist and evolutionary biologist at the University of Chicago,
just like a clam has an animal. Clamshell has an animal inside it.
So if two corals, a little fleshy wormy thing. Exactly.
And it wears it skeleton on the outside and because they sit in the same place
for their whole life, they're really sensitive to local environmental changes.
Meaning what I think about it this way, let's just just start.
Think about what happens to a creature as it lives its life in the ocean.
The water, which is what these things do. You know,
we live in a world of cycles of cycles on cycles. Temperature rises and falls.
A light rises and falls.
The tides rise and falls several times in the course of a day.
So you think about what that means for creatures living in water.
What it means for corals as Neil is that they're growing.
They're slapping on new skeleton, if you will,
new shell in time with these cycles,
rise and fall and light and dark, hot and cold. And hello. Hello.
Hi. You can actually see these changes written onto their shells,
maybe into their shells.
And that's why Andy Mills and I called up our pal Emily Grassley,
who's job is a chief curiosity correspondent of the field museum in Chicago.
That's your actual title, the chief curiosity correspondent? Yes, it is you.
You brought some corals, did you? We have many corals.
We have corals all over the a studio task right now. All right.
All right, let's cut. Cut It.
[inaudible]
because when you cut into these shells, oh,
it's warm and a little bit of water. We can spritz it on there to cool it off.
Right off. You can see a pattern.
You see these gray stripes and they're all,
I mean they're all different variations of gray,
but some are really dark gray and some are are Tan.
They're like bans running either through or across the chef.
They kind of radiate out like the bands of a tree and between the bands there,
there are
basis. If you've got a stripe,
then a space stripe and a space striped and space.
But when you hold it up close to your eye,
if you look closer in between the stripes you can see of,
wow, you can see the wines. Wow.
You can see that the spaces are filled with, with faint little lines.
And that's where the piece of this story is just so fascinating because in 1962
a paleontologist professor John Wells was looking at some corals just like the,
he's, he was just sitting there saying, okay,
well what can we figure out from coral shells?
So what he did is he did something really simple. He says, well, I'm Golly Gee,
what am I count
the number of little lines between these bands? Just yeah, just to see.
So he starts counting as you know, 100 200 lines,
301 300 ten three hundred and twenty and every time he counted, he got a number
round around 360 365 wait a second.
Familiar number. Now
doesn't take a lot of inference that hey,
maybe those individual rings represent, you know,
a daily pattern,
meaning each of these little lines actually equaled a day.
And why they're not just making a gray mark after three 65.
What are the gray lines? Well, the,
the thicker lines are the times of the year when the coral grows a lot.
But if you've got a summer core, all that, it grows a lot in one summer,
then it goes quiet, then it grows up in next summer. So that's again,
that marks a year that those big bands are kind of like, ah,
Eh, and a half
happy new year. [inaudible] happy new year. [inaudible]
happy new year.
They're actually calendars and clocks inside each of these things.
You just have to know how to read them. So this guy, professor wells,
what he did was then, this is the really, um, bold bet I thought,
which is, uh, he then said, well, okay, that's all living Carl.
Let's look at some fossils. He was after all the paleontologist know.
So here's a Cornell university.
Cornell University is surrounded by a rocks around, you know,
370 or so million years old.
And he collected some Nice Carl's in.
There are a lot of Nice coral fossils known from there.
And he opened up these ancient skeletons and he did the count and the hundred
days, 200 days, he was expecting a hundred days,
360 to 365 [inaudible] 68 then low and behold he found 400 between 404 10
really? Yeah. And he looked lots of specimens.
That number, the 400 number kept showing up. What is, what does that mean?
Well that means that it's,
it's now reasonable to think that back in the day, you know,
380 million years ago, there were more days in a year
[inaudible]
and he published a paper saying more or less that. And right away
clam scientist said, well,
if that's true for curls and it's gotta be true from my animal,
the clam and the oyster people said, well,
it's gotta be true for Oysters and muscle folks. Has gotta be true for Mussels.
This paper set off a bit of a,
a cottage industry of folks applying this technique to other species.
In looking at these other species,
they found that the general trend is absolutely correct that when you compare
modern animals to ancient animals,
you will find they record the old ones more days in here.
So you go back to a time period called the Ordovician,
which is about 450 million years ago.
A typical year had about 415 410 days in it.
If you go to the time period I work on in the Devonian about 360 million years,
probably about 400 so what you see is the number of days in a year has declined
from over 400 to what we have now, which is three 65 that's feeling so.
So we have lost 40 days since, yes.
Since since creatures first started to walk on land. So now comes the obvious
question. Why, why would there be more days and then than there are now? Okay,
wait a second, wait a second. Wait. That waste it.
So a year a year is a trip around the sun.
That's a trip if we are trying, and days,
days are when we spin it around and since we're going around the sun. Okay,
so that, so maybe if you want to squeeze more days into a year,
maybe it just means the trip around the sun took longer back then. Well,
if you ask astronomers about that,
I asked Chris MP at the University of Arizona and he says,
there's no sense that the length of time it takes the Earth to orbit the sun is
changing because the Earth's orbit around the Sun, this basic physics,
and it hasn't really changed significantly. He's pretty sure of that.
So then what is it? Well, Chris has,
the answer takes us back about four and a half billion years to a time when the
earth was very young.
So there was this crazy period of time lasting about 50 million years,
which they called the greet bombardment period.
There was still a lot of debris leftover from the formation of the solar system.
So the meteorite impact rate with thousands of times higher,
the earth was still like attacky magma. And so there was,
there was a hale brimstone, endless rain.
I mean the kind of crazy time really.
And a bit of that may him of course we think, uh, gave birth to the moon.
There was a huge collision and a rock about the size of Mars banged into us,
fung, a hunk of earth, shrapnel into orbit.
And those pieces coalesced and became our moot,
which is now sort of parked right next to us.
And so it sort of tugs us around in a kind of hefty way.
And we took to the moon. Oh, it's a, it works both ways. You know,
we tucked the moon and the moon tugs house in the forest is actually equal.
So it's kind of like a dance. It's a dance. I tried the moon and the moon today.
Exactly. It's a, so last year old waltz,
I see the
[inaudible] and
it's that dance,
that waltz that explains why the earth used to have 450 days in a year,
then 400 days in a year. And now only 365 well, I don't,
I don't see how this explains anything. Well, first of all,
let's just remember what a day is.
A day is a full spin of the planet from the sun coming up in the morning and
going down, coming up the next morning. So one spin, a total spin equals a day.
Yes, we all know that now today we make 365 of these spins as we orbit the sun.
That would be a year, but back when the earth was born,
when it was all by itself, dancing alone, that in those days it spun faster.
It was making more of these spins as it went around the sun.
So a year had more days in it.
But then along comes the moon to join the dance. And now here's the key.
According to Chris Earth is spinning faster than the moon is orbiting it.
A dance part. It takes a month for gum around us.
We take 24 hours fume,
and you know how it is when you're dancing with a partner who is slower than you
are, then you have to, you have to tug them along,
which is what has happened here. Gravitational,
we are constantly tugging the moon along.
It is constantly dragging us down.
There's a transfer of energy here that over billions of years has caused the
earth spin to slow down just a little bit, a teeny, teeny bit.
And as the spin has slowed, well, our days have gotten longer.
And if you do the math,
you calculate that the day is getting longer by 1.7 milliseconds.
Each century, 1.7 millisecond seed century.
What this means on a daily basis is that today was 54 billions of a second
longer than yesterday.
And the day before that was 54 billionths of a second longer than the day
before.
And the day before that was 50 foot billions of a second longer than the day
before that, which was 54 and if you extrapolate that out over the, you know,
millions of years, people like me, think about, that's Neil Shubin again,
the paleontologist, that becomes quite significant.
[inaudible] you're telling me,
you're telling me that today is the shortest day of the rest of my life. Yes,
Andy worries about these things. Well,
you're not going to live longer because of this. I'm sorry to say, but
no. So this Moondance does not affect the ticking of time.
It just affects what we choose to call a day. And by the way,
one of the consequences of this stances is we lose a little energy to our moon
every year and the wind picks up a little energy from us because these things
are always equal. Think about like when you throw a ball,
the more energy you use, the further the ball is away from you.
Well as we add a little more energy to the moon, the moon,
very slyly, who's a little further away from us every year.
It's about a couple of inches according to Chris, the length of a warm, really.
So the moon is getting a worm's distance further away from us every year.
And he says, if you go back about 4 billion years,
the moon was originally about 10 times closer than it is now.
Time is close. Imagine the moon looking 10 times bigger than it does now.
That would've been crazy. Also,
the days would have been a six hours long,
six hours long.
[inaudible]
all right. To me,
what this says is that everything that we take for granted as normal in our
world, you know, ice at the Poles seize and certain places,
continents configured the way they are, the number of days in a year.
All that is subject to change. And all that has changed.
All that has dramatically changed over the course of the history of our planet.
And that includes how we measure time itself. So, you know,
when I'm sitting in a hall, in the middle of the Arctic,
digging at a fish fossil, every now and then, you know, I pinch myself and say,
here I am in the Arctic,
digging out of fish pasta that lived in an ancient subtropical environment.
You know,
the juxtaposition between present and past sometimes is utterly mind blowing,
but it's very informed with about our own age and that we, you know,
we take, we think things are eternal but they're not there.
Everything is subject to change. Changes is the way of the world.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
special thanks to Neil Shubin, University of Chicago,
his new book is called the universe within and it describes how you and I are
linking. Oh so many ways to have bones are chemistry.
I cells also to Chris, MP, University of Arizona,
his newest is called shadow world and to Emily Grassley and Paul Mayor of the
Field Museum in Chicago, we called Emily, we said,
find us a paleontologist and a saw
[inaudible]
and before we go, um,
because it's the end of the year and who wants to leave when you've had a good
year and this, you know, and who knows what's gonna happen next year.
So I just want to play you a little bit of a, can we do this?
Can we just add an end to the end? Cause that's what I'd like. Sure.
I was talking to Neil degrasse Tyson,
who's an astrophysicist and who thinks about spin,
which we've just thought about, thinks about the inner solar system,
which we've just thought about.
So here's him and I talking about holding on to time.
It's a little goofy, but here it is just for the fun of it.
So if you're on earth and you're walking in, you know,
around Quito on the equator, um,
if you are walking at four miles an hour, you know, your,
your day will go of doing the normal way. The Sun will rise behind you,
go overhead and then go down the other side. If you're stationary,
if you're stationed at 24 hours a day, yes. Yeah.
If you started walking on the equator, depending on which direction you walked,
your day will either last longer or shorter.
Okay? So if you walk west, the faster you walk,
the longer your day will become.
You could walk at a pace where you have a 25 hour day of 27 hour day.
There's a speed with,
you can walk on the equator in the earth going West where your day lasts
forever. And that is the rotation rate of the earth.
You would have compensated table,
that would be a jury observable running on a beach ball, a rotating beach ball.
So that would on the top of her of a beach ball.
So that speed for the equator is about a thousand miles an hour.
So the equator moves a thousand miles an hour and that gives,
that gives us the 24 hour a day.
If you want to go a thousand miles an hour in the opposite direction,
you will stop the day.
The Sun will never move in the sky and you'll have it in your,
your day will last. Superman did that once.
I think when you had this thing with low superman would is so messed up
everybody on earth for having stopped the rotation of the earth,
reversed it and instead of forwarding, yes,
he would have scrambled all not anything not bolted to the earth would have been
blown off. Yeah. So at, depending on your latitude and equatorial residence,
if you stop the earth,
they were going at a thousand miles an hour with the earth.
You Stop the earth and you're not seatbelted to the earth.
You will fall over and roll due east a thousand miles an hour in our
mid-latitudes. Where in New York you can do the math.
We are moving about 800 miles an hour due east and stop the earth.
We will roll 800 miles an hour due east and crash into buildings and other
things that are attached to it to, all right, but let's going back to Venus now.
You want to go to Venus? Isn't this enough for you?
[inaudible] whole pointless to go to Venus because it's so different there.
Yeah, on every way. No,
it's about the same size and about the same surface gravity, but that's it.
It's 900 degrees Fahrenheit. It's a runaway greenhouse effect.
It is heavy volcanic activity that repaved the surface periodically.
So they're very few craters on Venus. I'm just unpleasant in Gen on place.
It rotates very slowly, but that's why I want to stop SLO.
So how slowly does it really? I don't remember the exact number.
One miles an hour or something like that. Yeah,
it's some very slow rate at its equator.
Slow enough so that you don't need special.
You don't need airplanes to stop the Sun. You don't need special speed devices.
You could probably trot and stop the Sun on the horizon or wherever the sun is.
So this guy, guy from Jamaica, what's his name? Hussein bolt.
Hussein bolt like and your,
you happen to be on Venus for a little while and you decide to go for a run.
What happens to Hussein during the run? Okay,
so normally the sun would rise in one direction and set in the other depending
on which direction you chose to run in. You could,
you could reverse your day and have the sun rise and the opposite side of the
sky than it normally would. And,
but I think Venus is rotating slowly enough that you wouldn't have to be Usain
bolt. I'd have to check my numbers.
I don't think you would in order to have the sun actually sort of seem to go
backwards as what you're saying is the sudden go backwards.
So you'd be having lunch, Usain bolt and you're going to say,
now I'm going to run and the sun's going backwards towards the mornings horizon.
You can reverse the sun. That's correct. In fact,
that is a really good reason to sprint. Um, I think, well,
but who cares about the sun anymore? Me If I were the same,
but I like go up these [inaudible] telling you when to eat lunch.
I don't think so. Your stomach is telling you when to eat lunch.
You're saying okay,
Hussein saying you eat breakfast but you want to have lunch real soon run so
that the sun is now at the top of the sky.
So now your your you can legally have lunch. No,
you're not buying my poetic a premise at all today.
The 21st Century Jack and his son is we we when we wake by alarm clocks,
not by roosters and sunlight. I'm sorry.
I wish I could help you out by thinking. Let's apply.
I'm not going to depend on running so that this on Venus to get the sun in the
middle of the sky at my command so that I can have lunch. Okay. All right.
But let's suppose you are a rooster and you like to crow at dawn.
You just a deep feeling you could totally mess with a rooster. This one. Yes.
That's what I want to do. Saying volt carrying a rooster with the same,
both carries a rooster on Venus. He does in the remarkably past sprint,
the rooster having started the run in the middle of the day,
well past the crowing period,
fuels a strange compulsion to crow two hours into the run. You,
because he ran backwards to the sunrise rather than he ran forwards.
But the sun went backwards. He went here. Yes.
He ran in the other way to reverse the sun back to sunrise. Yeah.
And then the rooster is going to, will need therapy
[inaudible] stuff.
Well, um, I think it's time for us to definitely go down. Yeah.
We should definitely get out. Okay. I'm Chad. I'm Robert. Thanks for listening.
[inaudible].